[Music]
Prince Harry and Megan Marco will say I
do and get this it seems expanding their
royal family isn't too far behind one
step at a time and we'll start of found
me in the future we've seen how Harry
and Megan love being around kids and
having some of their own could happen
soon after the Royal Wedding he's made
no secret about wanting children and I
think that moment for him really kicked
in when his brother Prince William of
course settled down with Kate Middleton
they had two children another one is on
the way and that has definitely gotten
Prince Harry very broody Katie is the
author of Harry life loss and love out
today she writes that harry introduced
Megan to little Prince George and
Princess Charlotte early in their
relationship to show her how Royals can
leave normal family lives you marry into
the royal family but that doesn't mean
you can't have a regular family with
cute children and hero George in
Charlotte just to show you that it can
happen I think that was really important